[Musique]
moi je chiffres la fraude sociale et
notamment la fraude à la carte vitale
avec les millions de cartes vitale qui
sont dans la nature a entre au moins 20
milliards d'euros au moins 20 milliards
d'euros
donc entre 15 et 40 somme paraît le bon
chiffre et ce qui est surréaliste
c'est que président de la cour des
comptes dit on ne sait pas c'est le seul
domaine où la cour des comptes ça vous
va il faut bien comprendre que ceux qui
volent les français et bien font en
sorte qu'à terme il ya plus d'argent
pour ceux qui le méritent et donc c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs dans toutes les
catégories sociales et notamment les
plus populaires il ya un ras-le-bol
parce que tout le monde sait que il y a
des centaines de milliers ont dit deux
millions selon le magistrat charles prat
2 millions de fausses cartes vitale 2
millions de fausses cartes vitale en
france ce sont des milliards d'euros
alors d'un côté on dérembourse des
médicaments utiles notamment
l'homéopathie on laisse des petits
retraités dans une situation de misère
et de l'autre vous avez et notamment il
faut que je veux dire aussi des filières
d'étrangers qui a luz de la france ce
n'est pas acceptable et peut demain
matin moi je vous le dit demain matin
faire au moins 10 milliards d'économies
sur la fraude sociale demain matin
qu'est ce que nous proposons est debout
la france c'est des cartes vitale
biométrique
on supprime toutes les cartes vitale
chacun va la rendre et en échange aura
une carte vitale comme un passeport
on a bien été capable de faire des
passeports dans les mairies on sera
capable de faire des cartes vitale
biométrique numérotés dans tout le pays
ça prendra moi je vais vous le dire ça
sera pas en un jour mais peut-être deux
ans département après département au
substituera les cartes vitale y aura des
rendez vous chacun viendra témoigner
on le peut le faire c'est une
organisation mais capable de le faire
devant il ya beaucoup de pays qui ne
font donc pourquoi en france on serait
le pays des voleurs et pas des honnêtes
gens
[Musique]
les gouvernements successifs n'ont pas
voulu lutter car il préfère s'attaquer
aux retraités aux pauvres français qui
n'en peuvent plus aux étrangers
réguliers qu'ils respectent les lois
plutôt pauvre voleur mais vous savez on
a ça partout puisque on voit des
policiers qui s'attaque à dézoner de
gens parfois et qui ne font rien face à
des délinquants parce que les magistrats
les libère dix fois donc nous sommes en
france dans un problème de rapport à la
loi
ceux qui respectent la loi sont en
permanence harcelé par l'état et ceux
qui volent la france sont en permanence
excusé par l'état hier j'avais l'exemple
d'un petit entrepreneur tout seul
coureur qui a 55 ans et qui a un
contrôle urssaf et au même moment vous
avez des gaffes à qui trichent avec
toutes les règles du jeu voilà le mal
français
donc c'est une question de volonté
[Musique]
mais l'un n'exclut pas l'autre
moi je veux m'attaquer aux voleurs de la
république j'ai écrit un livre en 2013
je crois les voleurs de la république
suite un rapport sur la grande fraude
fiscale la fraude à la tva des grands
groupes représentent 20 milliards
d'euros
alors moi je veux baisser les charges
des petites entreprises en récupérant
l'argent sur les multinationales
je veux que chacun physique dignement
dans notre pays en baissant les charges
sociales sur les salariés les retraités
de manière à ce qu'ils puissent vivre
dignement et on peut le faire il faut
simplement s'attaquer aux voleurs on
peut récupérer en france demain matin 50
milliards d'euros 50 milliards d'euros
et cet argent on va l'économiser d'une
partie et on va leur déployée de l'autre
c'est faisable mais ça veut dire il faut
du courage et du courage vis-à-vis de
ceux qui menacent l'état en permanence
qui menacent de d'une révolution qui
menace de violence
est ce que la france se faire respecter
c'est la seule question qui se pose
[Musique]